ce
bonjour à tous soyez bienvenue à ce
premier événement tedx organisé en
martinique
c'est un grand honneur de vous voir si
nombreux merci à vous vous nous donner
la force de continuer pour présenter
cette manifestation j'aurais d'abord
aimer remercier celui sans qui rien de
tout cela n'aurait fait n'aurait pu être
fait l'éternel qui nous donne la force
d'être là tous les jours et qui nous
aident à aller jusqu'au bout de nos
convictions
il ya bien sûr quelques individus que je
tiens à remercier qui ont vraiment
apporté quelque chose de fondamental à
ce projet tout nouveaux partenaires
seront présentés par la personne que je
vais vous présenter tout à l'heure mais
les individus que je veux remercier si
véritablement les parrains de cette
manifestation
je parle bien entendu de jeanne beaudry
et de qu'ici je vous demande accueillie
avec moi sur la ceni merci
ces deux artistes ont prêté leur talent
leur image que cette manifestation soit
encore plus belle je tiens les remercie
très chaleureusement je donne la parole
tout de suite à jeanne bozzi
merci laurent bonjour à tous je suis
donc jeanne baudray pour ceux qui ne me
connaissent pas chanteuse et comédienne
et accessoirement vraiment ravi d'être
ici aujourd'hui est ravi de vous voir
aussi nombreux
je vais donc commencer en fait tout
simplement par remercier laurenti pria
de m'avoir sollicité pour être la
marraine de cet événement parce que je
pense que son invitation je serai prêt
certainement passer à côté et j'aurais
manqué l'occasion de vivre une
expérience réellement enrichissante tant
à l'échelle de mon développement
personnel car qu'à celle de ma
perception de demont il ma petite île et
de ses grandes vidé o fut aussi la de la
journée vous aurez vous aurez sûrement
vos coups de coeur comme j'ai déjà pu en
voir les miens je vais donc vous
souhaiter de passer une excellente
journée en notre compagnie
je vais souhaiter à tous nos
intervenants de pouvoir avoir
aujourd'hui toute votre attention parce
qu'ils le méritent et je vais souhaiter
à ce tout premier tadic ce pan de france
de remporter également tout le succès
qu'il mérite
merci beaucoup
messieurs dames bonjour je m'appelle
kessi j'ai 29 ans et en tant que parrain
du tedx je suis très heureux que je suis
très heureux d'être là parmi vous et que
vous aussi vous être là parmi nous et en
ce dimanche 20 décembre 2015
je vous invite à partager avec nous un
grand moment de joie de bonheur de paix
d tre houle delà du réel mais sache que
je ne vous voit pas mais je vous imagine
merci de tout coeur de votre présence
d'être là avec nous ou tedx martinique
merci beaucoup
merci à nos parrains et marraines de man
de cette manifestation
c'est un grand plaisir de les avoir
parmi nous
oui